ma c'è un bambino miss abbiano dato una
mozzarella prendere un po di sole la mia
carnagione
certo con la carabina e genera e poi è
tutta una questione di melatonina cioè
il cielo provatissimo anzi all acqua
centro ma solo che le gambe non voglio
mica rovinarmi la piega ma vera e paura
delle meduse per quella che a me non mi
hanno mai punto ma perché lo sanno che
se mi pongono le deterioro guarda che
gli animali capiscono tutto ma il bayern
direi ma perché non sono ancora andato a
presentarmi non ci crede davvero
no chiamato a soccorrere una che stiamo
annegando però ho capito alla fine non è
manco il motivo cioè stop i mostri
troppo o birra ci hai ragione meglio
karaman così iniziamo a carburare per
stata ra